when was the first time Krillin met
General he obviously wasn't around for
the very first wish and as I showed a
second ago he wasn't around when
Reviving up his dad let's think King
Piccolo wished for use but Krillin was
well
then Krillin was revived by looking at
the manga here he never even gets a look
at shenlong just the top of his little
coffin thing as Shen long flies off so
let's say okay then it was Reviving Goku
and the San Arc but Krillin was of
training in the lookout with kame next
was Mr Popo Reviving the people of Namek
but of course Krillin was not included
since he was already dead again then
finally after the Cell Games the dragon
balls were used and Krillin was finally
there my brain is breaking the idea that
Krillin went that many years without
really seeing what Shen long looked like
is absolutely insane to me I mean okay
well he didn't get to see paranga but I
mean that doesn't really does that count